en allemagne de l'est il n'est pas
question de changement tout au moins si
l'on en croit le président à necker rien
ne devrait bouger
ce n'est pas du tout l'avis des milliers
de manifestants qui un peu partout dans
le pays demandent plus de liberté mirel
gorbatchev a quitté berlin qu'il n'aura
pas vu cadrede à berlin ou à leipzig on
demande est là aussi que soit appliquée
la pérestroïka pour les manifestants pas
question de passer à l'ouest ils veulent
le changement ici et maintenant nathalie
dollé
c'est un vent d'espoir et de liberté que
michael gorbatchev aura mené en rda ce
soir plusieurs centaines de soldats ont
été mobilisés pour contenir plus de dix
mille opposants qui réclament des
réformes aujourd'hui à dread leipzig ou
berlin les contestataires qui ont choisi
de rester en rda se sont servis du
numéro un soviétique comme d'un symbole
symbole de réformes sans pour autant
sortir du cadre socialiste les opposants
veulent continuer à suivre la référence
historique que l'union soviétique a
toujours représenté pour l'allemagne de
l'est
quand l'urss pratiquer une politique
d'ouverture la population de rda réclame
plus de souplesse une logique qu'eric
necker continue de nier même après trois
heures d'entretiens privés avec
gorbatchev le leader soviétique lui tout
en affirmant la souveraineté de la rda a
encore exprimé ce soir à moscou sa
compréhension face aux aspirations du
peuple allemand les aspirations à la
liberté et à des réformes que n'ont pas
encore compris les dirigeants